Several years ago, I was teaching one of my Bible classes and a really
important and significant book in the lives of most evangelical Christians came out.
And it created a firestorm of conversation, waves of controversy, and
all kinds of things happening in the Christian world.
The book was Love Wins by Rob Bell.
And I had all kinds of parents asking me if we were going to read it or demanding
that we don't read it. I had students asking me about it.
So I finally said enough is enough.
I need to figure out what the story is.
So I read it and I used it as a discussion point for my students.
Now the book had an incredible way of bringing up some really, really important
topics to discuss. But what was interesting is that the students seemed
to really gravitate toward what the book was suggesting.
That we somehow have this endless sort of chance by chance or chance after chance
cycle of getting to God. That if we don't, if we miss it the first time, we'll get a
second, we'll get a second try at it.
And that the idea of hell is really not all that accurate.
Now, it's an interesting conversation piece and something that we ought to talk
about. But the Bible is pretty clear.
Now, we've talked about the reliability of this text.
And Jesus is really clear that hell exists.
But it's so easy for our students to want to discount that because we don't
necessarily want to be held accountable to our actions.
And we don't really want to face the consequences.
I mean, who wants to face consequences?
So the question is often asked to me like, okay, well, what is hell like?
And I don't know, it's probably not nice.
I don't really know. I don't know if I want to know.
It's not God. Hell is the tragic consequence of
rejecting God. So to help your students understand what
this tragic consequence would be like, the intro experience
takes them through sort of a mini journey of imagining the best possible place, the
favorite place, why you love it, describe it, even put pictures in there,
and then remove all of its goodness.
Everything.
Cross out any word that has good meaning.
Remove all benefits from that place, all value, all joy, refreshing qualities, all
of it. What would that place be like then?
And that should help them get into that space of what hell would be like.
I often describe it to students, think of it this way, common grace is
the grace that God provides all of us, right?
The fact that God is sustaining this world, every breath that I take, the sun that
is shining, the air that is blowing, the trees growing, all the rain that falls, all
of the things that happen on the righteous and the unrighteous are all
common grace because God is here active and moving in history
and participating in sort of sovereignly taking care of this world.
Now remove all of that, and God is not doing any of that.
Can you imagine what it might be like to not be able to take a breath?
earth to not have the sun shining to not have this earth sustained
by him uninhabitable
it's kind of the way I try to paint a picture for hell for students to give them
that sense of like oh God is doing all of this for me whether I choose
him or not right so then the question comes, well, wait a minute.
How come God sends good people to hell?
How come God sends anybody to hell?
Well, the short answer is, is God doesn't send anybody.
We send ourselves because we choose to not want him.
You know, I've often said even that God honors our choices and allows us to choose
not him and then gives us that very choice.
So this week, small groups as always, but this week especially, is super
important because all that we're talking about is sort of going to come to a bit of
a culmination in the sense that how can a God that we've already said is good,
that's allowing evil and all those kinds of things, like how can he then have the
existence of hell be alongside that, right?
If God is so good and so loving and he allows this kind of evil, this is the
question that's been posed to me several times, is if God allows evil and
allows the suffering to happen, and he's so good, then why would he have
hell as a punishment for not believing?
Almost seems like there's a contradiction, right?
So these are some of the questions that your students may bring up or some version
of. Again, open discussion. It's okay.
If a student is not sure about hell, invite the discussion, invite the dialogue.
Don't shoot them down and just point to Scripture and kind of thump on the
Bible like, well, this is what the Bible says.
Well, yeah, and we've talked about the reliability of the text and the authority of
what's in there.
But hell is a very, very real reality that can be difficult for some people to deal
with. So be patient with your students as you bring them along if they're not quite
there yet. Allow them the time to process it.
And small groups are going to be one of those times where that's going to happen.
And again, it's understanding that God wants us to choose him.
God wants us to be with him. God invites us into a relationship, but he does not
force us.
And that is love in action. I want you to be with me.
Imagine being married to somebody that you love that doesn't love you back.
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
When you made it through this week, and you've almost made it through the rest of
the year,
we continue to pray for you here, and we continue to pray for your students.
And I hope that through this process of looking at hell
and evil and suffering in a very, very real way has helped your students understand
not only the point of suffering, but the character of God a little bit better.
and that not only that this points to the existence of God in some sort of
philosophical sense but that even in the midst of suffering God is right there with
us
feeling the pain along with us I hope your students have a better picture of who God
is and who Christ is and what their salvation means and all of that you have four
more lessons to go now would be a good time to take another inventory of your
students and then where they are go back to some of your original notes about how
your students started off this year and how they were around unit four where are
they now and are you got some students that have made some decisions I hope and pray
that you have do you have some students that still have significant questions if you
need to take some time and revisit some of those questions either as a group or
individually or in small groups, wherever you need to.
Don't rush this process. You've got four lessons to go, all of which
are gonna focus on wrapping things up and tying up some loose ends and helping to
send your students onward and forward into the world with greater conviction, with
greater confidence, and with greater courage.